welcome to this meditation and i'll
assume that if you are listening that
you have some type of major test or exam
coming up because that's what the title
of this meditation is about
now the word meditation can conjure up
different ideas to different folks but
all it is is a way for us to
observe our thoughts and maybe quiet our
thoughts down especially in a way that
makes us feel just a little bit lighter
a little bit more peaceful a little bit
happier and less stressed or anxious
and often times by doing that
it helps us do better on the thing that
we were stressed about in the first
place
so let's get started
so the first thing that i always
emphasize this is true whenever i
meditate is posture and breathing and
environment can matter a lot so find
someplace nice that you can sit down
ideally a little bit quiet or at least
where the sound doesn't bother you
and sit upright as well as you can
and if there is a little bit of ambient
sound don't let it bother you or
irritate you just accept that's the
universe making its noises just
something to observe it's almost a
little bit funny
and as you accept your environment
whether it's your external environment
or even sensations that you have from
your body
start to breathe a little bit deeper and
a little bit slower than you were before
this meditation began
breathe in
pause
and breathe out
and you can set your own pace for
breathing in and breathing out but just
try to go a little bit deeper and a
little bit slower
now when i do this i like to sit upright
usually on a chair and keep my hands on
my laps face up but you could do
whatever feels comfortable for yourself
now the other thing that i'll ask you to
do it might feel a little unnatural
is
force a smile try to make it as real as
possible but if you have to force it
and what i find is obviously when we're
happy we tend to smile but you can
actually make the wiring go the other
way that by forcing a smile it can
actually make you feel a little bit
better a little bit more positive
and try to keep that smile on your face
throughout the meditation and ideally
well beyond the meditation it doesn't
have to be a fake smile it could just be
a very slight gentle smirk if you like
but something that makes you feel a
little bit better
so with that continue to breathe in
breathe out
if you haven't closed your eyes already
you can gently close your eyes
and before i give you a chance to just
be with yourself quietly and observe and
maybe still your thoughts i'll give you
some ideas to think about
a lot of the
stress
of an exam
comes from identifying with the outcome
we get caught up with
what if i don't do well
or
i need to do well
or
i'm going to do so awesome that when i
do awesome all these amazing things are
going to happen in my life
the problem with getting attached to the
outcome
is the outcome may or may not happen all
those fears that you have may or may not
happen
all those hopes you have may or may not
happen
and so when you identify with those and
if they don't happen well that might
create a little bit of a disconnect
between yourself and reality and that's
one of the the number one reasons why
people get unhappy
reality isn't working out the way they
want it to
instead
you could identify a bit more with the
process the adventure saying look i have
this thing coming up
and i'm going to put my best foot
forward i am going to
put in the work to prepare
and i'm going to enjoy that work
i'm the sentient being on this planet in
this mystery that we call life and i get
to engage on this challenge called this
test
let me enjoy these moments
before you know it you're going to be a
lot older and you're going to reminisce
about this moment in your life right now
and you're going to laugh at yourself
why didn't i enjoy it more
now that notion of focusing on the
adventure of preparation i'll give you
another visualization that i find really
useful
imagine that your subconscious is a
massive ocean
and your consciousness the part that
thinks to itself here i am i'm some type
of pure awareness trying to observe and
make sense of the universe
that's a sky that's clear and full of
sunlight
and most of us
are operating on the surface of that
ocean most of the time
there are all these random thoughts that
are just
bubbling up from that ocean
waves that are crashing into our
consciousness
for many of you it might be thoughts
ruminations about how you're doing on
that test or thinking about consequences
of doing well or not well
and
it could be other things it could be
things going on in your social life
assignments that you have do
things in the broader world that are
troubling you
but one of the ideas behind meditation
is to realize that those thoughts that
are surfacing from your subconscious
they aren't you
and you can actually rise above those
thoughts
rise above the surface of that ocean
so imagine yourself as just a pure
awareness
rising above that surface
and you realize that all of those
thoughts that were thrashing around that
were splashing against your pure
awareness your consciousness they don't
have to
now you're above them and there's just a
few drops that every now and then you
can giggle and wipe off a bit
and you can look down on the surface of
that ocean and from a distance those
thoughts really don't seem like that big
of a deal
and as you look down on those thoughts
you begin to appreciate that they're
starting to slow down
the ocean is starting to become a little
more still
and as you continue to breathe in
and breathe out
there you are
just in that sun-drenched sky above the
ocean
you are that sun-drenched sky above that
ocean that is your subconsciousness you
are that pure sunlight
and with that idea in mind i'll give you
a minute of silence where you can just
breathe in
breathe out
and experience joy in that sunlight that
you are in experience joy in not getting
caught up in those thoughts
if your brain wanders off if your
consciousness goes back to the surface
of that ocean and that starts to get a
little bit choppier
no reason to worry about that just
remind yourself giggle a little bit and
say oh i got lost in the ocean again on
the surface with those waves let me just
rise up again
so i'll be back in about a minute
all right so we are back
so continue to breathe in
breathe out
hopefully you experience just a little
bit of stillness even if it was for five
or ten seconds the experience of
knowing that you aren't your thoughts
knowing that you can observe your
thoughts
knowing that there can be moments in
your life where you are free of your
thoughts
and now as we're winding down this
meditation
keep a couple of big ideas in your head
remind yourself not to focus on the
outcome but to focus on the process and
to enjoy it that smile that hopefully
you still have on your face
have that smile the whole time that
you're preparing
have that smile as you go into whatever
type of test or exam you're about to
take on
and if you can
try to take a little bit of time out
every day even if you could do it for a
minute two minutes three minutes where
you can sit silently with good posture
breathe slowly deeply
put a smile on your face
and rise above your thoughts
i feel confident that not only are you
going to enjoy this experience but
you're going to put your best foot
forward on that test
and you're also going to realize over
time
that this test isn't that big of a deal
many things in our life that in the
moment seem like a big deal
with a little bit of distance of time
and space
aren't that big of a deal
so if you haven't already
i encourage you at your own time and
pace while you continue to smile and
continue to breathe in
and breathe out deeply
gently
open up your eyes and take joy in this
adventure this mystery that we call life